hey guys how's it goin so I'm back in LA
and I was tweeting with Joey today
joking about going to catch pokemons but
apparently it now is not a joke and
we're going to catch pokemon so I'm
taking Maddie he looked like a little
girl today cuz you have their gut and I
put him in pink look at these boys look
at these boys just having a good time
they really like you really like looking
Maddie preserves looking at all the
interplay nice nice storm got so big if
you yeah oh my goodness hey Maddie
hey let's play nice that's please nice
hey let's let's leave the baby alone
guys there is a poky stop up here
there is a pokey stock of Mirotic we
gotta get them okay
so far I've got 24 50 like did you get
it
oh but when it smelled it means even
have it let's see the struggle of
catching pokémon is real Mady especially
bees enjoying this or hating it
hochi stop right up here got him Rhyhorn
and the pokey stop it's right here we
got it we got it we got it I got stopped
right here it's that - we're now minute
I got it I made you get oh we got three
I only do this how do I do this oh you
just think I'm a minute Bennett I think
good let's see she gonna get it what got
Jenna cry not easy
what's happening so we're at a poky stop
but where is this place at like where's
the clock
we might be able to it's pretty far
still since Jim is too far away so
heading up here there's like some pedal
oh my gosh there's one is one here too
it's a parent Maddie I got to get the
Pokemon yeah look at how the module
installed what you see it we're at a
freaking thing there's a gym no but look
see it that's right there get out
there's a module install it's a motto it
attracts more pokemons charger phone
Joey on the charge just go back from
Pokemon hunting with Joey and cat and I
got a shower because I was sweating so
bad it was so incredibly hot and I'm
heading to dinner with my lovely girls
so excited haven't seen them in a while
since I missed VidCon I missed the girls
love panel and I'm very sad that I
missed it but I had a really good time
in Europe so I'm sorry to anyone who was
at VidCon I actually really missed you
guys and it was so sad to see how much
fun everybody was having but I'm off to
dinner I'm hungry still jet-lagged
confused as to what time zone I'm on
scene a little bit Maddie oh my god you
think it's a mint you're about to eat it
and then and then
oh you guys miss it the first time
science so previous to this clip I was
hunting Pokemon and when I rolled up to
the restaurant I was hunting Pokemon in
the uber you guys really what are you
doing already so I just got back from
taking Maddie for a really long walk
preachy did you have fun on your double
you did you catch some Pokemon today so
his game is really crazy and as I
previously mentioned
I've never played Pokemon before have
you played Pokemon before so not really
sure why I never played Pokemon so the
whole Pokemon world to me is completely
foreign I never got into it when I was
younger most of the games that I played
were Mario games and then obviously when
Goldeneye came along
that's when I realized that I really
love first-person shooter games and then
from there I got into I guess I would
have been probably halo after that and
then once I got into PC gaming I got
super into I'm rich tournament and quick
thirty and then here we are where we are
today because that was a long time ago
the point in the matter is I don't know
anything about Pokemon so hanging out
with Joey and he's like naming all these
pokemons I'm like I don't know what
you're talking about this is they don't
it just means nothing to me
but the whole concept of pokemons go is
unreal it's making people leave their
houses first of all to play video game
and it's using sort of real-life objects
destinations that you have to go to
other people are able to interact with
it the dangerous thing is playing
Pokemon and driving
last night I took an uber to dinner to
meet the girls and it was great because
I was able to play pokemon collect the
Pokemon and not have to worry about
getting in a car accident because I did
read an article about somebody who did
get in a car accident in a little of a
highway because they were playing
Pokemon go it was so interesting about
yesterday is going out and walking
around in the streets is you could see
the other people that were playing the
game and trying to get to these specific
destinations so that they could collect
pokeballs and it was really really crazy
I'm a huge fan of augmented reality
which is why I really like the hololens
I feel like that type of game play an
interaction for me is kind of like
taking your already real world
surroundings but turning them into
something that's a little bit different
I'm just rambling because I wanted to
end this vlog but I guess I should show
you guys some of the pokemons that icon
feel free to leave me some comments and
tell me anything that I might need to
know about Pokemon because this is crazy
but is also extremely interesting is
this game as getting people who were
never into Pokemon previously into
Pokemon like me okay why is my GPS
signal not found so I have 78
here's my eggs five kilometers wow
that's far I know what you guys think
Pokemon goes it's not a sponsored video
by any means none of my tweets have been
sponsored a lot of you like oh my gosh
how much you getting paid to talk about
I'm not I'm not it's just really fun
okay I think I'd later I'm gonna edit
this vlog and probably try to catch some
pokemons well Matty is so itchy
Madi say bye say bye bye honey
my baby's hit she